Cette vidéo est une Parodie, je ne suis affilié D'AUCUNE manière a Nintendo ce n'est pas une vidéo sponsorisée ni une publicité, mettez un Pouce Bleu afin de libérer Hyrule
J'plane sur Hyrule, J'tourne comme un vautour
Comme un Russe sur Youtube, j'escalade les tours
On m'a pas donné d'voix, j'communique en sous-titré
Mais des fois (Ouais des fois !) J'fais des onomatopées
*Cri de Link de Majora's Mask*
J'suis en forme, j'ai dormi 100 ans, j'reviens du passé
J'ai des armes solides, un coup...
Merde ! Elle est cassée !
J'suis un cordon bleu, j'cuisine comme un chef
J'fais des plas douteux, Sponso masterchef, j'te mets quoi ?
Un lézard ou deux ?
Parfois j'sauve l'humanité
Parfois j'cueille des champignons
Mon équipe est dure, TEAM GORON !!!
J'fais des Snaps de mes Saps, sur ma tablette Sheikah !
Ma p'tite Tenue Zora va faire kiffer Zelda
J'crée des bombes a l'infini, rondes et carrées à la fois
J'peux pas prendre l'avion, impossible pour moi d'passer a la douane
Les énigmes ça rend fou, on va finir par m'interner
Même moi j'regarde j'avoue, la soluce sur Internet !
TRIFORCE !
Paratonnerre sur le torse !
Contre Ganondorf !
J'ai eu le courage d'affronter la canicule
Le blizzard, les orages
et libérer Hyrule !
TRIFORCE !
Paratonnerre sur le Torse !
Contre Ganondorf !
J'ai eu le courage d'affronter la canicule
Le Blizzard, Les Orages !
Et libérer Hyrule !
J'suis frais, j'suis mignon, dans tous mes Opus
FAUX !
Ouais bon là... C'était les débuts, hein. Euh... A 2 ou 3 pixels près, bon attends j'recommence
Millionnaire en rubis, j'collectionne les chevaux
Faut qu'ton poil soit uni, pour être dans mon écurie
Ouais c'est vrai j'suis petit, mais faut pas m'prendre de haut
En paravoile au dessus d'toi j'entends pas c'que tu dis
Paye ta boisson ! (Santé !) J'paye mon glaçon
Tu m'as copié en Cosplay, mais t'es une contrefaçon
Quand j'me bats j'fais n'importe quoi, j'sais même pas c'que j'fais ?
Dix mille objets dans mon sac, j'sais même pas c'que c'est
Avant, j'pétais des poteries, des vases et puis des jarres
J'étais la hantise de tous les potiers du royaume
Encore un coffre qui est fermé, j'ai pas la clé, j'en ai marre !
Offre moi un passe-partout si tu veux m'faire un cadeau
Tous les soirs, j'fais mes prières, devant la statue déesse
J'aurais 20 en endurance, si j'étais en EPS !
J'galère dans les sanctuaires, sacré Miyamoto !
Mais quand j'déprime trop, j'ressors l'ocarina poto...
Mon, épée y'a personne qui l'arrête...
Quand je parcours les donjons
Mais là il m'reste qu'une demie vie, et...
J'ai tisé toutes mes potions...
J'm'appelle pas ZELDA !
Mon nom ils le connaissent même pas...
J'veux sombrer dans le lac Hylia...
Ouais respirer sous l'eau j'peux pas...
*Bruit de Game Over*
Navi : Hé, Link ! Link ! Reviens bro'
Hé, j'en peux plus de toi là, j'suis au bout d'ma vie ! Tu m'fatigues
Link : TRIFORCE !
Paratonnerre sur le torse !
TRIFORCE !
Contre Ganondorf !
J'ai eu le courage d'affronter la canicule
Le blizzard, les orages
Et libérer Hyrule !
TRIFORCE !
Paratonnerre sur le torse !
Contre Ganondorf
J'ai eu le courage d'affronter la canicule
Le blizzard, les orages
Et libérer Hyrule !
*Berceuse de Zelda*
Zelda : Link, j'ai vu tous tes combats
Tes efforts
Ce courage...
Tu as combattu tant d'ennemis pour venir me délivrer
A mon tour maintenant...de te donner ce que tu mérites
C'est à dire...
Un grand merci !
Link : Ah, juste un grand merci ?
Zelda : Oui
Link : Ah, donc on s'marie pas, genre euh... on a des enfants, on a un pavillon et un labrador ?
Zelda : Non
Link : D'accord --'
Peut-être juste un p'tit contact physique ?
Zelda : Ah, oui pardon...
Link : Ah ouais donc, j'me suis fait friendzone quoi... c'est c'est
Lourd...
Norman : Hé, il parait que si tu cliques sur le p'tit rond là
Et qu'tu t'abonnes ça fait un son de Zelda !
Jhon Rachid : T'est sérieux la ?
Norman : Ouais, c'est un truc Youtube !
Jhon Rachid : Nan mais genre là, si les gens ils appuient depuis leur téléphone ou leur ordi sur le petit rond et qu'ils s'abonnent
Ça fait un son d'Zelda ?
Norman : Mais oui ! Vas-y essaye !
*Bruit de Coffre Zelda*
Jhon Rachid : Oh putain ! Génial !
Norman : Pouce Bleu ! C'est la Triforce !
C'est la triforce!
Ouais abonne-toi!